So the code that the attacker
wants to craft is basically code
that is going to launch this command
shell that we're talking about.
And that kind of code
is called Shell Code.
So how do you write Shell Code?
Well a little bit of expertise comes in.
So the Shell Code as I
said creates a shell,
which is going to allow you to
execute arbitrary commands.
So any code program that we have,
the attacker can ask that that
particular code be executed.
So let's talk a little bit about
how do you craft the Shell Code.
Say call you're making
to launch a shell,
you can write the code in C for example.
It's a fairly short piece of code,
you're just using one of the calls.
And then let's say you compile
it into assembler instructions.
So once you have assembly instructions,
remember the shell code
has to be machine code.
Because these are values and
they have to be encoded properly and
things like that.
These are values that you
are going to store in memory.
That is where your shell code is.
That's where control is
going to be transferred.
So memory is going to
store these binary values.
So it may look like data, but
actually it really represents
instructions of codes.
And if your program is instructed
to go execute from there,
then it is going to be a program.
So you really have to figure out
what the instructions are and
what data those instructions
are going to use when they execute.
And you're going to craft
that as a set of values
that you load into this part of memory.
And that's going to be based on the
instructional codes of the machine code
as I've said before.
But the way you can do that
is by writing the code in
a high level language, Assembler,
translating that to machine code and
that's how you figure out what is
the ShellCode that you're going to need.
So Shell Code that we going to
place somewhere in memory,
this is how you're going to get to it.
Then I say,
we know how to transfer control to it,
because we modify the return
address when the function ended,
it will actually go to this
place where the shell code is.